Robert Spencer more and more Muslim
candidates Across America are running
for political office State local and
National will they be loyal to the
American Constitution as Jefferson hoped
or does the Quran come first which does
not compote well with the American
Constitution on certain civil rights
well Barry you know every individual
candidate is going to have to make that
determination and some will no doubt
follow the Constitution and some will no
doubt follow the Quran the problem is is
that the question you just asked can't
even be asked it's ruled out of uh hand
ruled out as islamophobic and racist and
bigoted and so on and never even
answered when the reality is is that
there is a lot of contradiction between
Islamic law and American law so when you
have Muslim candidates then you have to
it's perfectly reasonable to ask are you
going to follow Islamic law or American
law like for example this is not a
political candidate but Rashad Hussein
the head of the office of international
religious freedom
when he's there defending International
religious freedom and he sees Muslims
persecuting Christians as per Islamic
law does he think that's a violation of
international religious freedom or not
but you can't even ask it's islamophobic